es ist eine einmalige chance der
menschheit zum ersten mal wird eine nova
jahre im voraus vorhergesagt demnach
wird sie 2022 am nachthimmel als
gigantische sternenexplosionen zu sehen
sagen vielen dank an den themenvorschlag
von luzie wären diese explosion wird
sie voraussichtlich die energie abgeben
wie unsere sonne während ihrer gesamten
existenz ab straße ein gigantisches
ereignis zwei sterne kollidiert und
explodieren in einer roten nova und wir
können diese explosion mit bloßem auge
sehen
sensationell wann und vor allem wo wird
das passieren
das thema jetzt endlich zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen so wird wie
aussehen eine rote nova in den tiefen
des weltraums von jetzt auf gleich
explodieren fall sterne und leuchten
10.000 mal heller als vorher dafür ist
der ausbruch von v8 38 monot erotisch
der am sechsten januar 2002 entdeckt
wurde
begonnen hatte er wahrscheinlich bereits
am ersten januar aber da hatte ihn
nämlich noch niemand entdeckt denn das
ist der haken bei solchen ereignissen im
riesigen weltall im vorhinein zu wissen
wo ein solcher ausbruch stattfindet so
möglich die chancen stehen eins zu
einer million
wie beim lotto doch jetzt scheint der
astronom lorenz müller von calvin
college in den usa einen solchen
einmaligen treffer gelandet zu haben er
hat nämlich beim doppel sperren knc 983
2227 eine erstaunliche beobachtung
gemacht diese beiden sterne scheinen
sich nämlich immer schneller zum
greifen genau das ist schon was 2008
passiert damals explodierte der
doppelstern v130 1 kopie auch ihr
umkreisten sich zwei doppelsterne immer
schneller und verschmolzen schließlich
mit einem rötlichen scheint genau das
soll jetzt auch passieren allerdings
wird es drei erhebliche unterschiede
geben macht es zu einer absoluten
länder zur erstens wissen wir wann es
passieren wird und zweitens wissen wir
wo es passieren wird und drittens was
der absolute hammer ist wir werden diese
explosion mit bloßem auge erkennen
können das hat es noch nie gegeben
mollner und seine kolleginnen und
kollegen haben sich den doppelstern in
den letzten zwei jahren nochmal sehr
genau angesehen und tatsächlich steuert
alles auf die nova 2000
23 zu die begeisterung am college in
michigan ist riesig das wäre ein
bedeutendes ereignis nicht nur für die
wissenschaft sondern auch weil es die
menschen auf der straße faszinieren
kann so koautor matt ward wenn die
vorhersage stimmt dann wäre dies das
erste mal in der geschichte dass eltern
auf eine dunkle stelle am himmel zeigen
können und sagenweg kinder dort
versteckt sich ein stern der balkan hell
aufleuchten wird ja und dann würde auch
tatsächlich aufleuchten wahnsinn genau
hier im sternbild des schwans würde
sein und in den wochen und monaten
vorher wird es wahrscheinlich immer
genau möglich sein
den exakten zeitpunkt vorherzusagen wenn
ihr bei der produktion deutsch
spannender videos dabei sein wollt und
bei pixum mitmachen wollt dann bewerbt
euch wir suchen zur zeit eine
praktikantin oder einen praktikanten
für den schnitt ich freue mich sehr auf
eure bewerbung an bewerbung at krachten
punkt net der link ist auch normal und
mit der video beschreibung und zur roten
nova ich kann euch jedenfalls
versprechen dass ich bis dahin ein
eigenes teleskop haben werde und es
natürlich auch das sternbild des
schwans ausrichten werden wenn es neue
zu dem thema gibt dann halten wir euch
hier natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn
ihr kein video dazu und zu den
zahlreichen anderen themen hier
verpassen wollten durch mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergiss nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit erste
aufzeichnung einer supernovaexplosion da
konnte vor einem jahr durch die
helligkeit änderung einer ganzen
galaxie der ausbruch einer supernova
verfolgt werden das war schon eine
absolute sensation wenn es euch
interessiert auf jeden fall drauf
klicken und wenn nicht dann bleibt dran